let me guess you all know who this is
right hey guys it's Billy I just want to
introduce myself hold up Billy not
Kendall Jenner Billy this is an AI
version of a globally recognizable icon
which if they could replace Kendall
Jenner can they replace you or better
yet can you replace you today we're
embarking on a journey into the
extraordinary world of AI design
together we'll explore where the
architects May soon find themselves
collaborating with or competing against
AI for the future of architecture we'll
be breaking down three AI tools which
are rapidly changing technology as we
know it including how you can create
your very own Billy to take your seat at
the table if you're new here allow me to
introduce myself my name is David Tomic
I'm a registered architect here in
Western Australia and I'm thrilled to
welcome you to my very real Channel
today we're diving into the captivating
world of architecture and design
exploring how AI Technologies can
Elevate or potentially destroy our
careers as design professionals let's
embark on this journey with the
architectural phenomenon known as D5
High an AI rendering system from the
creators of D5 render here AI technology
is at its peak and Architects might find
themselves in unfamiliar terrain One
path excels the trajectory of our
careers whilst the other symbol I izes
the end this tool was initially designed
with architects in mind but it's so
remarkably user friendly that it's
Paving the way for technology to
potentially replace the conventional
architect with D5 High there's no need
for extensive training or years of
architectural expertise to create unique
forms it's as user friendly as scrolling
through your favorite apps imagine
having endless design variations at your
fingertips without the traditional costs
of hiring an arch
it's a game changer and you should
probably be a little bit worried that's
why you should also smash that subscribe
button down below to make sure you stay
on top of these technology Trends and
aren't Left Behind one of d5s most
impressive features is the Imagine
variations think of it as exploring a
multitude of designed possibilities all
driven by this AI technology these
variations can be shared with your
clients or if you are the client
potentially even back to your architect
for us it's about embracing technology
to redefine the collaboration between
architect and client and not putting our
ego at the front but also let's not
forget that even in this era of
technological transformation there are
still limitations D5 High primarily
focuses on architectural facades
excelling in the exterior delion and
transformation of spaces however when it
comes to material selection and
intricate interior design detailing it
might not offer the fine tuned expertise
of a traditional architect think of it
like a brush that paints in Broad
Strokes it's perfect for creating
stunning facades but it still cannot
replace the Keen Eye of professional
architect when it comes to the
nitty-gritty of materials and intricate
interior decisions D5 high is a
groundbreaking tool for architectural
facade design it's user friendly it's
fostering a technological transformation
and it's raising questions about the
role of Architects but it isn't quite
ready to replace us Architects just yet
that is until our next AI tool
superchargers D5 high in a world where
AI is inching closer to reshaping how we
design Our Living Spaces let's continue
our journey by unlocking the potential
of photoshop's generate tool think of it
as your architectural Genie but without
the limitations of just three wishes
it's here to fulfill your endless design
dreams you remember the story of Aladdin
right he discovers a magical lamb home
to a genie ready to Grant his every wish
well photoshop's generade tool is a bit
like that Genie except you're not
confined to just three wishes you can
conjure up an infinite number of Design
Concepts and just like Aladdin all you
need to do is rub that metaphoric lamp
in our case that means upload a photo
and provide a text prompt ridiculously
simple it's remarkably userfriendly even
your grandma could probably use it if
I'm being honest you can be as specific
or as vague as you want with your wishes
similar to Aladdin's wishes it Tex
prompts become a reality in a matter of
seconds whether you desire a cozy
Retreat or a modern Masterpiece the
generate tool takes your vision and
breathes life directly into it no magic
words required but here's where it gets
exciting you don't need to be a design
expert to wield this magic with just a
few clicks you can experiment with
colors furniture and layouts it's your
own personal creative journey and you
are the master of your very own journey
of course like any magical tool there
are caveat it's not just always going to
Grant your exact wish there are going to
be unexpected surprises the quality of
your starting photo is so critical to
the end result and replicating that same
wish can be a bit like trying to wish
for the same thing twice it's just never
going to happen at least not identically
for now it's primarily for sparking
ideas rather than delivering fine-tuned
ution layering photoshop with D5 High We
Are One Step Closer to revolutionizing
the design process and replacing
traditional Design Studios but
personally I'm not even close to worried
designing endless variations is all well
and good but architecture is still
personal and AI can't just replace you
and I can it we're venturing into this
futuristic Frontier and creater AI is a
Cutting Edge platform that's
revolutionizing the way we interact with
AI cror AI is akin to platforms like did
offering a unique and Innovative
approach to human and AI interaction it
can serve as a human replacement for us
transforming text into lifelike speech
and animation hello and welcome to the
channel this is an AI animated voice and
design crer AI operates on the
principles of using generic human AI
models for text to spe conversations
offering a seamless experience that
feels like you're interacting with me
right now you can engage with these AI
entities for a wide range of
applications from content creation right
here on YouTube to customer service and
representation but you see here's where
it gets truly intriguing Creator AI
offers the option to create an exact AI
match of yourself so you can transform
yourself into a digital persona it's a
fascinating blend of technology and
self-expression this is similar to what
meta did with the kendle Jenner example
at started this video they simply took
her Essence and created created a
digital clone known as Billy if we
imagine the possibilities from creating
content with a virtual twin to offering
personalized customer experience with an
AI representative Creator Ai and
platforms like did open the doors to a
world where humans and AI interaction is
seamless and the boundaries of
creativity are being pushed to brand new
limits however it's important to
acknowledge the current limitations the
model used by crater AI like many other
AI systems out there have their flaws
and most of the time it's very easy to
recognize them as digital Creations
rather than real humans the
possibilities of fully replacing humans
with digital versions is still limited
today if you're on a budget if you like
meta well then you don't have a budget
and you can do some amazing things you
see the future may not be as far away as
we think as technology advances the
lines between the digital and the
physical world are already blurred it's
not inconceivable that in the
architectural field at least your
architect you could become partly
digital collaborating with Advanced AI
systems to create extraordinary designs
the future is taking shape before our
very eyes we as humans and AI in the
background working hand inand inspiring
the realm of design and Technology now
as we conclude this exploration of ai's
evolving role in design we stand at the
threshold of an intriguing question can
AI potentially repl Place Architects
from the quick transformations of
photoshop's generative tool to the
architectural magic of D5 high and even
the mindbending possibilities of Credo
AI we're witnessing the ever expanding
capabilities of artificial intelligence
the potential is boundless yes and AI
continues to make strides in design
offering Creative Solutions that
challenge our traditional perspective of
architecture whilst we're not there yet
we can't ignore the exciting prospect of
architect's collabor ating with AI to
achieve groundbreaking designs but
that's all for me team I'll see you next
Friday